[Applause]
tuesday so uh governor cuomo has just
resigned
uh a lot of people sending me dms like
yo your work is done that's what you did
you got him out of here yeah i don't
think that i played any part in getting
him out of here i think that um
he was probably getting a little handsy
with these girls and uh you'll take the
credit for getting him out of here i
will take the credit okay listen we're
feminist dude you can't disrespect women
and they have let us you know not on my
watch yeah and you can't disrespect
italians you can't wait what was he
doing to italians well he said i'm not
perverted i'm just italian that is true
and that's offensive to italians that
are listening to it being like hey
we're also perverted too exactly
exactly why would you take perversion
away from italian that's what i'm saying
right it's disgusting yeah yeah i'm not
a pervert i'm just it's like bro like
own it it's so insulting
i am perverted and i'm italian
it's an umbrella and everything's
underneath it and i don't think any
italians are upset about this do you
guys think no chance i mean this guy has
daughters
i'd be really curious to see how he
feels if someone treated his daughters
like that
would he look at them be like are you
italian and then they're oh yeah yeah no
big deal it's okay trying to finger my
daughter that's totally fine
we'll talk about it
it's one of my favorite pizzas oh just
smell the seed that she sat on because
you're italian yes sniff her garlic knot
that's all that matters you're italian
that's the excuse for everything right
let thousands of people die because
they're old you stuff them into this
home and you write a book about it yeah
it's an italian thing exactly
yes it's our culture they all live
together they're very family oriented
they're communal oh that's true
not family oriented stuff them in the
coveted and let them die that's what
mussolini would have done yes he would
have he is the greatest italian leader
oh my god
they tried to they tried mussolini said
i'm not i'm not a dictator of fascists
hickory dickory dock
i sent your grandma to the dock
[Laughter]
i thought i could have done better with
that
jack and jill went up there i fingered
my maid
[Laughter]
what is that how he goes my name is
governor cuomo
what's another uh androidized clay line
i only know the hickory dick mother
goose mother goose i don't know what
happened no what is something she left
what was it what was it uh oh [ __ ]
checking something something
uh oh god i'm forgetting it dude i'm
having a moment yeah no damn yeah i
completely forgot dude like everybody
that cuomo killed
during covet you see that a little
memory lapse did you forget about that
when you wrote a book about it you piece
of [ __ ]
what a piece of [ __ ] if he didn't write
the book it's defensible yeah
if he didn't write the book
like if he didn't write the book he can
he can lie
and say i didn't touch anybody
inappropriately right
and he can say we did the best that we
possibly could we didn't know it was
gonna happen in this way and we so
regret it but when you lead you have to
make decisions and people end up dying
because of those decisions and that's
the cost of leadership and i think you
could have like bowed out gracefully
right but the fact that he wrote the
book
the numbers it's so tragic get it dude
cannot come back yeah you cannot come
back like if oj wrote a book like if i
did it you know what i mean it's just
you're rubbing salt in the wound you
know what i mean
cuomo's walking around new york like
dude i'm afraid i might be near the
governor that killed everyone
oj
is a pariah you can't be around him i
know al wants him on the podcast it
would make me feel uncomfortable to have
him on the podcast because he killed two
people
of people
alex jones if you want to get on our
podcast you gotta kill thousands of
people you gotta come back alex jones
just said people didn't die
he just said people didn't die and then
that guy's completely cancelled cuomo
killed thousands of people
and there's a good point thousands of
people he killed he killed that he made
a decision to kill thousands of people
right he made he said thousands of
people are [ __ ] dead because the
decisions i make and i'm gonna lie about
it sweep it under the road then write a
book about how great of a job i did he
patted his own back for killing those
people he celebrated his money
celebrated it and he's cancelled for
patting some fanny
that's what he's canceled for because
fanny came up to him and he just pat pat
pat
he also did worse stuff though what did
he do i think he was good alexander went
under the shirt
that's italian that's italian dude sorry
listen
you're not respecting other cultures
dude there are certain cultures that you
have to respect and like he said this is
an italian thing if a girl walks by him
with a skirt he has to lift it up
he has to lift it up it's marilyn monroe
he has to lift it up and you have to
smell her fanny dude do you see that big
[ __ ] mug of his yeah you think that
big mug isn't huffing anus nonstop in
the office dude
come on mark
have some respect no that's
[Applause]
this big nose is not used for smelling
fantasies
he's ruining the name andrew he's
ruining the name andrew dude also what
self-respecting italian names their kid
andrew that's not an italian name
andrea or something like that andres i
don't know what it is but andrew is a
strong scottish name and chris oh
christopher columbus i guess i guess he
even knows where that [ __ ] is from
right running away from his [ __ ]
problems little [ __ ]
i want to go to the end of the horizon
i think the world is round
i think it's wound the world
what a [ __ ]
oh man what did he do sailed the wrong
way sailed the wrong way how do you go
the wrong way dumbass it's the very
beginning yeah i wish he got to y'all
honestly delta might not be happening if
he did that's a good ass point yeah
that's a good answer this is hey we're
that's a good idea we're doing
reparations for american indians we're
giving you all some sickness for once
wait a minute keep going okay
you guys killed all the other indians
with your [ __ ] smallpox blankets yeah
we kill you guys with our rocket thing
is is out of come on there's no way how
many blades are you giving out how many
blankets how many blankets it's one how
they gotta share the blanket yeah
there's a blanket they're cold there's
only someone okay so we gave two or
three blankets and then all the native
americans just died it's a contagious
disease dishonesty
nobody talks about disease and wuhan
nobody's one scientist nobody talks
about how well they slept and i think
that's the important thing is that's the
first they slept too well that's the
problem they took the great sleep
they had the great sleep yeah the great
sleep the one that lasted forever yeah
okay that's the problem but that's the
thing there's a blanket thing i don't
buy it i don't buy it i think maybe it
happened bro where do you how many
blankets would you come into the new
free world do you bring 75 blankets
where do your blankets are from where do
you think they're from uh pottery barn
they're from china from pottery barn
exactly they're not from china they are
from china and then you got kovid i
don't get anything oh [ __ ] new balance
american-made okay
stone island
england england okay carhartt yeah
american-made
yeah what do you got on
uh all his [ __ ] is
that's how i got it we're not gonna talk
about alex's shirt that's what we're not
gonna do
is talk about alex's shirt right now if
we're bringing up chinese shirts hey
r.i.p chicks
[Laughter]
hickory dickory dock
uh i still think cuomo needs to write
the book i know we've talked about this
before he's got to write the book on uh
on not sexually harassing women
oh no we didn't know we talked about it
before but i think it's i think it's
still worth it he has to write the book
about how he wrote the book about how to
handle a pandemic even though he killed
a bunch of people or it's it's not even
about not sexual arrests he has to write
the book about how to do office hr yeah
he wrote the book about how to handle a
pandemic write the book about how to
handle your office yeah
it could be a self-help book even if you
could do that the secret call of the
secret brisket that's what he told us
that's what he told his staffers
definitely a secret i love this idea i
think it's a great idea i think that
what was some of his rules right he had
that one rule where like women are have
to sit on stools but upside down so he
makes them turn upside down and then
just pick a peg and then you sit on that
and that's where you do your work that's
just to make sure everyone has a seat
exactly
all three women sit back to back on that
stool
slot it down okay and then what happens
afterwards
okay shave off the stool into a cacho
pepe okay that's how he makes the
pharmacy tell me what hate tell me when
real talk i think he has to do that what
are we gonna call it
i like the secret i think the secret is
good um how to win win friends and
harass your staff yeah yeah that's a
good one what else that's good yeah um
the sexual harasser next door you know
the sexual harasser next door that's
good okay what is that book called the
dummies or the idiots guys yeah
yeah what is it sexual harassment for
dummies sexual harassment no it's just
management it's like office hr for
dummies right okay how to finger women
you don't know when they come close to
you for dummies for italians for
italians it's the culture i'm sorry i'm
sorry
i always get confused i walk down the
street with my girl and someone hollers
at her i'm like are you italian he's
like yeah i'm like that's fine
i agree i'll tap him up i'll be like
yeah of course dude if he's german i'm
gonna fight him you have to fight him i
know but he's portuguese brazilian
whatever i gotta fight him it's a
cultural thing you have to respect
culture don't we respect culture
that's a good point that's what american
progressives say they're like listen i
understand in certain countries they
take the gays up to the highest building
and they see if they can fly yeah right
exactly do that and then americans go we
have to respect these other cultures we
cannot intervene yes italians have a
culture that's all andrew cuomo is
saying maybe he's from a specific part
of italy
which is way more rapey than the other
parts right and that's why he has to
constantly funnel tits and try to finger
girls he's sticking fingers and slits
the guy's a slit-fingered chip nipple
sauce monkey oh that was nice he
is that well done he's a slick finger
and chimpable sauce monkey i said it
again i'll say it three times fast he'll
appear right now trying to finger us off
okay
but he's candy man i think he is from
his family's from nipples
dude you keep slipping up like that i'll
have alex finger bang you right now okay
while you sit in that goddamn seat
payback's a [ __ ]
okay payback is a [ __ ] he's gonna paint
my back real talk
okay honestly cuomo you need to put some
respect on him
okay he's italian it's just respect the
culture not cuomo respect his culture
i don't think that that's italian
culture but that's how he's
characterized
as a non-italian
question an italian who am i who am i i
mean we say this all the time who am i
to speak on behalf of black people okay
the perfect person but outside of that
who am i to speak on behalf of indians
i'm not india exactly who am i speaking
on behalf of french
or gays okay i'm not that yeah okay who
am i to speak on behalf of italians
italians is that we're talking about
yeah oh i was thinking of one for me
scots
okay scots scots germans irish i'll
speak on behalf of them americans i'll
speak them a half american exactly i
can't speak on on behalf of a talent i
think people might call you ugly and
you're like i'm not ugly i'm just
scottish whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
[Laughter]
how
[Laughter]
i'm the most handsome man ugly dog i'm
not i'm the most handsome
ugly alex alex alex don't even start
okay and also with his forehead let's
not get in
let's not get this also he said indian
smell as if he didn't smell himself i
said you don't smell i said you're just
indian you don't smell you're just an
indian guy i'll accept that from them
but not you yeah yeah yeah yeah he
smells the worst but he's also french
they do have a true little odor to them
okay so he ain't french
that's right no are you french i was
born in france that council okay he
wasn't born in france where was i born
you weren't where was i born you weren't
you were born here
and then you moved over there no i was
born in paris he's lying is that a lie
he's lying dead ass
you're lying you worry about it why
would i lie about it miles says he
wasn't born there miles toby wow
wow he's been lying i've been lying is
this the bellyache part two i had to
impress you guys why would that impress
us because i'm french yeah but we don't
care about that well i didn't know that
we resent that yeah i'm going
yeah you're going for a weekend it's
nice for a weekend you know what i mean
yeah that's what my parents said too
when i was born there then they left
well don't take your girl to italy
because god knows what'll happen there
why what will happen what will happen i
mean italian culture again we don't know
if that's italian culture i know plenty
of italians that do not are you really
going to explain it's also not wrong if
italians do it exactly yeah i don't know
what i'm trying to say is he's
characterizing italians in a way that
that might piss off attacks how can you
question an italian all i'm just saying
i'm not going to go out there and say
this is all italians i'm not going to do
that because he might be
mischaracterizing italian yeah that's
just what i'm saying because i have
plenty of italian friends and they're
not just walking around trying to finger
girl slip ciao they don't do that they
don't do that [ __ ] okay that might just
be him and maybe his specific region i
know that italy is very tribal and maybe
that's what he's trying to say okay but
i know that he's out there he's kissing
guys he's i mean he said this himself
he's like i kiss guys i grab girls i do
i do this i grab powerful people there
was a picture with him and clinton he's
like grabbing clinton's face kissing him
a lot of people grabbed clinton's face
and kissed him i don't know if it was
that way or the other way around all
right guys we're gonna take a break from
this exclusive patreon clip that you can
find at patreon.com flagrant2 because i
gotta make sure that you got the hardest
dick you've ever had in your life yes
i'm taking it upon myself to make sure
your dick is hard if you're a girl
watching this ladies your man's dick
should be even harder than it is you
want to have a fun night you want to
have a fun weekend well blue chew is
going to provide that for you okay
you're going to be blowing backs out
with the blue chew that's what's going
to happen that's what's going to happen
that's what's going to happen it's the
same active ingredients as inside cialis
or viagra but this is the true this is
the one we work with this is the one
that we make sure our girls are
satisfied with if you've got a girl
you're trying to leave an amazing first
impression on
it's blue chew you got a wife that you
need to give a romantic night to is blue
chew you got a side piece that needs
great dick delivered it's blue chew and
you're gonna get it for free all you
gotta do is pay five dollar shipping at
bluechew.com use the promo code andrew
okay that's bluechew.com promo code
andrew you get it for free all you got
to do is pay five dollars for shipping
and you can have the hardest dick in
your life make sure you use it
responsibly now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon okay so what's the
takeaway from this what's a takeaway uh
don't uh sexually harass women is one
potential takeaway i also learned a lot
about italian culture personally okay
i've been curious about that culture for
a long time yeah nice to know yeah nice
to know don't go to olive garden
okay uh because if there's cuomo type
italians there it could be not as fun
that's true yeah that's true yeah and
alex what did you take away from this
i don't know which one is worse i still
don't know
killing old people or groping women or
growth in women yeah okay yeah i guess
what you're saying is they're both
horrible like groping woman is so bad
that it's almost akin to like i think
killing all people should have resigned
for killing the old people but it was
the 11 women because he killed the old
people by mistake he groped the women on
purpose oh that's a good point but
death is bad though i'd rather i'd
rather get killed than have someone
assault me well it depends how they're
assaulting me they might assault you in
a way that makes you want to die he
fingered my ass i'd rather that happen
to be dead right now you'd rather your
ass get fingered than be dead
actually
yeah no no you would rather get bent
over and then someone would just dig
away
it was not with my consent i did not
bend over he took no i'm just saying
hypothetically speaking if you got bent
over and someone was just jamming gun
finger into your ass would you be okay
with that i don't know i don't know i
think death might be better than that
one
simply that yeah yeah yeah all right
fair enough okay so cuomo gets what uh
was coming to him now what about chris
cuomo what about the brother cnn
some people saying he's got to go yeah
mike gotta go complicit
ah
because wasn't he an advisor yeah so he
was aware of these things hypothetically
speaking he's aware of these things let
his brother put out the book promoted
that [ __ ] book promoted his brother
saying he's the best they had their
stupid little brotherly love uh you know
facetime calls or zoom calls on the air
teasing everybody oh go see mom oh
where's mom i know there's a lot of moms
that aren't to be seen anymore because
of both of you right
so should he be accountable for what's
happening maybe chris cuomo is the real
italian he didn't snitch he basically
took a blood oath he said nothing you
can't get my brother through me i'm not
a [ __ ] stool he's not a fredo we
always thought he was a fredo he's
actually he's not afraid he rides he
rides he's ride or die that's
interesting he's right i would if chris
cuomo was like what i'm just italian i'd
be like nah that makes sense that's
italian that one makes sense yeah that's
a great point chris cuomo was italian
yeah you could chalk up anything to
italian yes you can yeah yes you can
okay so but what what do you think
happens with them because we all we all
the time try to hold uh
facebook accountable for misinformation
that's out there we try to hold these
different platforms instagram twitter
accountable for misinformation and
spreading of fake news and the effects
of the spread of that fake news well
what happens if you suppress news what
happens if you work as the person who
delivers the news to the people and you
actively suppress and help somebody who
was murdering thousands of old people
they say he wasn't allowed to talk about
it which is convenient which is
convenient but
that happened afterwards yeah
while it was happening he was allowed to
talk about and chose not to while he was
also advising his brother right so he's
get he's on the payroll he's getting a
couple shekels from the family right
while at the same time running coverage
for his ass on cnn
and calling out everybody and their
mother on his channel that's the issue
that's where you [ __ ] yourself if you're
cnn especially those nighttime guys it's
very pious it's very self-righteous
everybody else's behavior is deplorable
you
advise your brother who's doing that
kind of deplorable [ __ ] now you got to
go
interesting akin to writing a book it's
the [ __ ] news reporter equivalent of
writing a book about what a great job
you're doing what is there to talk about
today i don't know yeah nothing there's
a few thousand old people that aren't
around anymore but who cares let's not
talk about that we'll talk about the
death numbers every single day on this
network we'll talk about how deadly the
virus is yeah every single day in the
summer we'll have a ticker looking
running how many people have died the
last thing we'll do is say the old
people that were stuffed in the home by
my brother and that i knew about
potentially or allegedly knew about it
yeah this number is a little lower than
it should be because we're we're not
counting those
that's a little wild you gotta go so
there might be something about just
being governor of new york because
apparently this is the second governor
of new york that resigned over sexual
misconduct who was the last one the
elderly
oh spits oh legend apparently actually
nope nope
yeah
yeah
that's
shut the [ __ ] up for the next few
minutes so this podcast doesn't get
canceled nah they're legendary
pedophiles that's what i'm trying to say
i let you finish yeah if that's exactly
better but i see what you're saying no
okay but yeah
he got in trouble with the prostitutes
in 2008. spitzer spitzer did i think
soliciting sex across state lines is
that what they got him on across if
anyone ever says across state lines i'm
like what does that mean i don't even
understand it's called the man act or
something like that prostitutes across
state lines i don't know chappelle had a
joke about it once i think it's called
the man act yeah it was like some old
law that they got him on or something
like that that was passed apparently to
get jack johnson who
loved [ __ ] white girls and he was the
first black heavyweight and they just
wanted to bring him down so they were
like that was passionate he knows a lot
about this law right here
you know how about the law you know who
went down
so what happened but no he he resigned
you so now cuomo is the second governor
to resign over sexual misconduct in the
last like what 12 years do you think
it's possible that there's a straight
politician that is over 60 years old
that hasn't
been uh oh
[ __ ] good question that hasn't been
handsy or weird uh two women that were
close to them obama
yeah
hey maybe i don't know i said straight
but i think
wow
he just turned over 60 and obama been
done oh yeah sure eight years now he
doesn't qualify because he's just that's
right he's not he's not 60. he just
turned 60. okay yeah do we think there
is and now he's through the homeowner
this is why this is why i asked all
these women say we need reform well and
i think they might be right but this is
why they ask i don't think that we need
reform for the average person so this is
what's tricky right
politicians are supposed to represent
the average man or the average woman
right and they have this uncanny ability
to be relatable right you hear them
speak and you're like oh my god that guy
really reflects uh some things that i
see in me like bill clinton apparently
is so [ __ ] charismatic when you meet
him he makes you think like you're the
most amazing person the most interesting
person he's ever spoken to right
so
we see his flash cards with you know
some of his dates and wait does he yeah
exactly on the plane to have scenes
island that's what he does he's known
for that wild boy over here oh i didn't
know about that but clinton does that
yeah he's very friendly yeah yeah
anyway these are all allegedly okay you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] he's a victim yeah
allegedly
andrew cuomo
was assaulting this man the guy's a
victim heard people heard people how you
know it didn't start with cuomo and then
after that he was like i need to go to
that island
i need to do what was done to me to
someone else okay cuomo is the first
vampire yeah he bit clinton what's the
opposite of retirement home epstein's
island that's what i'm talking about
exactly okay now so back to back to this
back to this point
which i forgot what the [ __ ] was i
saying yeah yeah so this is supposed to
represent the people yeah so the
politicians represent the people we
think that they are like us and that is
their schtick that's their gimmick and
convincing yes their gift is convincing
us they're just like us they're one of
the people but they also can lead the
people and they have these great ideas
they're going to take care of us right
what we often don't see in these people
but is true is an insatiable desire for
power
insatiable if you want to be a
politician you desire
power yeah and it can there's there's
certain people who
maybe they want to be politicians
because they want to help right
but even if you want to be a politician
because you want to help
you also desire power yes okay most of
the people i know that want to help just
go help they work for a not-for-profit
they're still underway
like those most of the people i know
that really want to help they just do
that tons of ways to help the best
possibilities
never want to be a politician like the
best leader it never
100 now so these people want to be
politicians they want to win the
elections they want to have the power
power power people who have this
addiction to power yep right why do you
have an addiction to power because you
like to use that power you like the way
that power uh people treat you when you
have that power right there is something
dangerous there is something nefarious
that comes with the yearning for power
yeah okay i'm not surprised that people
who are addicted to power are willing to
dedicate their life to being in
positions of power
act weirdly around people and try to use
that power around people especially
those that are less powerful and get off
on the usage of that power around the
people that either depend on them or are
less powerful and kind of have to do
with what uh what they're saying yeah
they don't stop expressing their power
exerting it over people they're not
serial killers right they're not like
serial rapists right they're not that
horrible with it where like they need to
feel powerful and they're going to
imprison a [ __ ] woman in an addict so
that they feel all the power and control
over that person right that's what like
the sierra rapist serial killer some
[ __ ] you see on [ __ ] law order svu
right that's that kind of stuff that's
the extreme version they're like right
before that
right they're like right here right so
what i'm trying to understand is if you
had that like
disgusting disease inside you yeah where
you just constantly crave this power
is it that shocking that you're gonna
use it
especially around your staff and
especially around the the sex that you
are attracted to if you're gay it's
gonna be the dudes you see this
happening in hollywood all the time gay
dudes doing it to dudes straight dudes
doing it to women right you see it in
every different field i mean even
powerful women will do it
yeah we know a good friend of ours
had a powerful woman do it to them
that's what i'm saying like there's this
famous quote that i always think about
this like
uh great men are hardly ever good men
and like i kind of think that's true
yeah like to be great in the sense that
like you've done something like
substantial like governmentally or like
politically or something like that we're
talking like the elites of the elites
it's hard to get there by being a good
guy
and yeah and the type of qualities that
take you to the top of being like you
know a fortune you know 100 ceo or
something typically makes you a little
ruthless there's an oral ambiguity you
have to have where it's like i know
that's probably what's right but this is
what gets us where we need to go so yeah
i shouldn't you know
try to coerce my intern to sleep with me
but i can and it's not is it really
wrong but they rationalize things in
their brain in like a specific way she
wants it yeah that's what they tell
himself she wants it and what would
happen to me
what could happen to me i'm so powerful
that nothing can happen yeah right and
they really start to believe this [ __ ]
and that's why they're absolutely
terrified by like me too movement and
these other movements because they're
like wait a minute my power doesn't work
yeah usually i just quiet these people
usually i tell them hey i'm going to get
you a job somewhere i'm going to get to
a movie role i'm going to get you a
political position you're going to be on
someone's staff so you would rather be
on the staff you have these aspirations
for a political career wouldn't you
rather be on someone's staff
then complain about me and i can put you
there it goes both ways though like
that's why i don't like when people get
super tight when like uh people
criticize like historical figures like
they're like oh maybe abraham lincoln
wasn't like a perfect guy i'm like yeah
probably not yeah like he was he lived
so long ago like he was a super powerful
person one of the most powerful people
in the world like yeah yeah he probably
[ __ ] up a lot and did really egregious
things yeah so like i think that goes
for anyone that's quote unquote great
yeah yeah the thing is that you've got
to judge greatness within a vacuum right
like we're dredging like the athletic
greatness within a vacuum like there are
athletes that probably were pieces of
[ __ ] maybe neglected their families
weren't great husbands but they still
average a [ __ ] triple-double one
season then oh my god okay that was a
great season that was you don't become a
less good basketball player because the
[ __ ] you did outside your life right and
abraham lincoln doesn't become a less
good politician because of the things he
did in his personal lives or the way
that he treated people etcetera right
you also need to judge those figures
based on the time they lived in yes
that's also an important component yeah
100 but there's just overreactiveness
when people say when people look
especially like american history even
current politicians where they're like
oh he's perfect he's great he's great
he's great that people that especially
feel victimized by the things that they
did do whether it's like racist sex is
homophobic then they'll come out and be
like no he's actually the worst yeah
it's like he's not the worst and he's
not the best he's just a human being
that did good things and also [ __ ] up
now as far as cuomo goes like you can
look at the good stuff he did be like
all right and then also
you know punish him and [ __ ] on for the
[ __ ] up things you're a product of
your time you're a product of your
culture but i'm never surprised when
great men do [ __ ] up things i'm like
yeah you're going to abuse your power
that's what that's why you want it it's
not about like a great man thing it's
just like man does [ __ ] up [ __ ] man
woman does [ __ ] up [ __ ] great men have
a spotlight great men have a ledger
people are remembering it everything you
do is a great man gets minted to the
blockchain okay so every single thing in
george washington's life once he became
that dude yeah becomes important oh he
chopped down a cherry tree i don't even
know if that was him
you know what i said it was him right
he's like how many [ __ ] chopped
down a cherry tree you didn't know that
you don't know what the [ __ ] you did in
your backyard yeah nobody knows until
you become great and then all of a
sudden that story about you in high
school one time in high school he
actually you know helped this person
with a wheelchair across the street now
that's part of your story you're the
wheelchair helping guy and there's also
something to power corrupts and absolute
power corrupts absolutely like a lot of
those guys are wired that way but also
if you're just a regular guy who gets
power you can still probably go that way
pretty easily yes 100
uh 100
what up people you just watch a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you